c'est l'heure du second débat de sens
public des bas de société
consacré à l'écologie radicale parfois
violente des affrontements avec les
forces de l'ordre pour empêcher la
construction d'une méga bassine au jet
de produits divers sur des tableaux de
mètres les actions de jeunes militants
interroge avant d'entendre l'analyse de
nos invités artage avec les activistes
de dernière rénovation c'était vendredi
le bloquait le périphérique parisien le
matin à l'heure de pointe Samya dechir
et emo Touré
8h30 sur le périphérique parisien une
dizaine de personnes longe les voies
et s'interpose face au véhicule pour
bloquer la circulation
ils sont nombreux de dernière
rénovations un collectif qui milite à
coup d'action médiatique avec une
revendication bien précise pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique de
tous les bâtiments en France qui réduira
les factures énergétiques de tout le
monde qui créera des emplois locaux en
France et qui réduira nos émissions à
gaz à effet de serre ça c'est gagnant
gagnant-gagnant nous on veut ça on exige
gouvernement face à tant que
gouvernement fait pas ça on prendra les
mesures radicales comme celle-ci de
bloquer la circulation d'impacter la vie
des gens pour vraiment envoyer un signal
fort certains ont collé leurs pour
ralentir l'évacuation des forces de
l'ordre
excéder des automobilistes tentent de
déloger eux-mêmes les bloqueurs
[Musique]
l'opération est risquée mais la méthode
rodée en quelques semaines le collectif
dernière rénovation a déjà bloqué une
dizaine de grands axes francilien on est
tous pour le climat mais là moi
personnellement je me rends à l'hôpital
et je vais faire une copine et on est
embêté dès le matin d'être bloqué sur le
périph ben c'est c'est beaucoup plus
haut que ça se passe ça se passe c'est
pas c'est pas nous pauvre citoyen on
fait des gestes au quotidien mais c'est
pas en bloquant les autres les autres
personnes que ça va ça va changer
quelque chose en fait la circulation est
totalement paralysée certains
conducteurs perdent rapidement
qu'à la hauteur quand on compare à ce
qui nous attend bah c'est incomparable
après je suis d'accord que ça peut être
désagréable et je suis désolé pour eux
mais on n'a pas le choix en fait et
c'est pour eux qu'on le fait aussi et
c'est pour leurs enfants les membres de
dernière rénovation ne sont pas tous des
militants à guéris il se disent simple
citoyen venu réclamer un grand plan de
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
français d'ici 2040 comme si était
engagé le gouvernement après la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
pour la plupart cet acte de
désobéissance civile est une première
fatiguée des marches pour le climat ils
assument une forme de radicalité les
pétitions les manifestations parler aux
politiques ça n'a toujours rien changé
alors voilà où on s'en retrouve on se
retrouve à bloquer des routes et oui ça
peut paraître incohérent mais en fait
il y a beaucoup de violences à côté mais
en fait au regard de
au regard de l'illégalité du
gouvernement se délit n'est rien du tout
est-ce que les villes de toutes les
personnes qui meurent de froid chaque
année de toutes ces de tous ces ménages
précaires ne valent pas plus qu'un
blocage de 30 minutes
une fois les renforts policiers sur
place les bloqueurs sont rapidement
évacués leur action aura duré une
trentaine de minutes
emmené au poste il resteront plus de 9
heures en garde à vue certains ont
courent jusqu'à deux ans de prison pour
des lits de travail à la circulation
jusqu'au ira la violence des écologistes
radicaux est-elle indispensable ou
contre-productive on en débat tout de
suite avec Isabelle sommier bonsoir
bienvenue à vous professeur de
sociologie politique au Département de
sciences politiques d'université Paris
Panthéon Sorbonne et vous avez dirigé ce
livre violence politique en France
publiée au presse de sciences pool et a
Falco bonsoir bons du collectif pour un
réveil écologique j'accueille également
Antoine bueno bonjour bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes essayiste conseiller au Sénat
en charge du développement durable
auteur de l'effondrement du monde entre
parenthèses Nora probablement entre
parenthèses pas lieu voilà pardon c'est
compliqué maintenant mais c'est votre
titre donc on essaye de le respecter
Flammarion Laetitia cruppa évidemment
est resté à mes côtés je voudrais je
vous propose et je vais révéler un peu
des coulisses de la préparation de cette
émission un peu de sémantique moi j'ai
dit là dans pour présenter le débat
jusqu'où ira la violence des écologistes
radicaux est-ce que vous parlez de
je vous posais la même question à tous
les trois sur les événements de ces
derniers jours et quand je dis ça je
pense plutôt à Sainte Soline et Oméga
bassine vous avez raison de penser au
Méga bassine parce que il y a différents
degrés la radicalité n'est pas forcément
associée à la violence mais par contre
au risque de l'illégalité ça très
certainement alors il y a des degrés
entre s'attaquer à une œuvre d'art par
ailleurs protégée cas jusqu'à présent
faire de l'entrave à la circulation
comme le reportage vient de le montrer
et ensuite faire du vandalisme et aller
à la confrontation avec les forces de
l'ordre comme dans le cadre des
mégabassines c'est quand même trois
choses différentes et je vois bien les
scinder dans ce débat absolument et donc
je parlerai plus de radicalité que de
violence même si ça peut aller jusqu'à
l'avenir
quand vous avez parlé de questions
sémantique je pensais que c'était une
autre partie de votre phrase que vous
alliez interroger la partie radicale
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
finalement que radical sémantiquement
radical ça veut dire aller à la racine
donc je pense qu'il y a un vrai problème
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition qu'on fait
entre le radicalisme et l'extrémisme
c'est à dire que c'est pas des synonymes
c'est important de les discerner et on a
une opposition dans le débat public
assez constante entre les écolo radicaux
qui font globalement un peu n'importe
quoi et les écolo pragmatiques c'est à
dire des gens qui sont au gouvernement
par exemple qui peuvent faire avancer
les choses ça c'est la perception que
vous jugez caricaturale un petit peu
parce que pragmatisme que ça veut dire
ça veut dire faire quelque chose
intelligemment efficacement éradical ça
veut dire i à la racine la face à
l'urgence environnementale pas seulement
climatique il y a toute une
questionnement derrière qui vient de ça
veut dire quoi aller à la racine ça veut
dire régler le problème vous avez fait
de la sémantique sur radicalité c'est
passionnant et sur violence je pense que
c'est quand même important que dans le
cas d'urgence environnementale le
radicalisme c'est du pragmatisme que par
conséquent l'inverse c'est vrai aussi et
alors violence ou pas sur la violence je
rejoins tout à fait ce qui a été dit il
y a tout un de la violence je sais pas
si c'est une solide c'est de la violence
en tout cas c'est effectivement ça se
construit en dehors du cadre qu'on
considère par ailleurs d'habitude comme
un cadre de manifestation mais dans le
cas en tout cas de des gens qu'on vient
de voir qui bloquaient une autoroute je
considère absolument pas ça comme la
violence mais c'est un moyen d'aller à
la racine et bah c'est une bonne
question je pense que c'est un moyen
d'éclairer en tout cas un problème ça le
résultat c'est sûr et certain mais il y
a d'autres étapes après et ça questionne
aussi notre traitement médiatique ce
sera l'une des parties de ce débat votre
avis sur ce qu'il adapté génial votre
première question parce que quand vous
avez présenté les choses et j'ai noté la
phrase exactement j'ai noté la phrase
parce que je trouvais que la
présentation était justement biaisée le
fait que vous posiez la question
justement remets complètement à plat le
débat je pensais pas que vous le feriez
effectivement donc c'est la violence des
écologistes radicaux encore faut-il
considérer que c'est véritablement de la
violence à pas alors moi je j'ai pas de
compétences étymologiste etc etc mais je
je rentrerai pas la dent mais pour moi
non c'est pas véritablement de la
violence surtout ou alors il y a des
degrés il faut vraiment qualifier et la
radicalité c'est pareil est-ce que c'est
véritablement radical j'en suis pas
certain voilà mais j'ai effectivement
frémi frémit c'est peut-être ex mais en
tout cas réagit quand vous êtes toute
une partie de la rédaction de public
c'est là qu'il y a aussi été mis quand
j'ai utilisé ce titre donc c'est pour ça
moi je suis transparent avec vous que
j'ai décidé de d'ouvrir le débat de de
cette façon alors cette radicalité je
vais employer ce terme-là Isabelle
sommier sur l'écologie elle est pas
nouvelle de quand vous la datez est-ce
que je peux revenir un petit peu parce
que évidemment on a le point de vue de
l'activisme et effectivement ce qu'on
remarque c'est que aujourd'hui les
activistes se revendiquent volontiers de
la radicalité ce qui n'était pas évident
parce que quand le terme radicalité
arrive il arrive d'abord par
radicalisation à propos des attentats
islamistes quand même en France donc
effectivement les activistes ils disent
voilà nous on pose les questions on va à
la racine des choses donc on va jusqu'au
bout et on interroge
on pose un problème public mais c'est ça
l'objet de ces actions spectaculaires
etc du côté des adversaires et de ses
activistes et des cibles éventuelles de
ces activistes on parle au contraire
beaucoup plus volontiers
trémisme
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui radicaux
c'était les extrémistes les extrêmes
d'hier des années 70 d'une certaine
manière moi je dirais que la radicalité
l'engagement radical il y a deux
principes d'une part il y a une posture
de rupture vis-à-vis d'un ordre
économique politique etc qui en théorie
accepte en théorie au moins le recours à
des formes non conventionnelles donc
illégale et pourquoi pas violente mais
ce qu'il faut bien noter c'est que la
radicalité c'est tout le temps
relatif et relationnel c'est à dire que
c'est une transgression d'une norme mais
une transgression d'une norme qui est
perçue comme
subversive pour l'ordre politique et
social alors que le délinquant il
transgresse une homme mais il est pas
perçu comme transgresse comme super
José Beauvais les champs d'OGM est-ce
que c'est est-ce que c'est une date
importante oui bien sûr c'est une date
importante puisque avec ses actions
entre à la charnière des deux siècles en
2003 il y a la figure de la
désobéissance de la désobéissance civile
et parmi les différentes gradations que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure évidemment il
y a l'action directe non violente la
désobéissance
et la désobéissance civile et cette
question de la désobéissance elle est
absolument centrale et à l'intérieur des
franges qui revendiquent ce recours à la
revendie à la désobéissance il y a aussi
des nuances en jus quoi aller action
directe non violente action directe tout
court pourquoi pas sabotage Antoine
BUENO dans une interview Aliexpress dans
laquelle vous parlez de de votre livre
vous dites que les extraits écologistes
se cherchent un bouc émissaire et
hésitent encore entre trois bouquets
mystères les vieux les riches les mecs
oui ah non alors là on parle pas du tout
de la même chose
toutes ces actions là cette activisme là
ce dont je parlais dans cette dans cette
tribune c'est l'instrumentalisation de
l'écologie qu'on pourrait rassembler
dans le terme de de d'un écologisme et
je parlais en particulier de Sandrine
Rousseau voilà parler de Sandrine
Rousseau et effectivement il y a une
graissation quand vous dites elle oppose
de générations je vous ai lu donc
pardon peut-être que vous avez changé
d'avis vous en avez le droit mais moi on
va au fond du débat moi ce qui me ce qui
me dérange énormément c'est qu'on parle
énormément de l'écologie mais des
écologistes et qu'on parle pas
d'écologie et pardon mais c'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire là mais je vais
venir sur le traitement médiatique et
sur le fait qu'on est plus parler de par
exemple on y viendra pour les pour les
tableaux tout à l'heure et que on a plus
parlé des tableaux que des rapports du
GIE avec c'est totalement absurde dans
le traitement médiatique je suis 100%
d'accord avec vous mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez dire par cette idée de bouc
émissaire et bien ce que je veux dire
c'est que si on parle d'écologie mais
effectivement on va essayer de faire
porter le chapeau à une catégorie de la
population par exemple les riches ou
bien les hommes dans une optique déco
féminisme etc etc et donc on va pas
prendre le problème dans sa réalité
factuelle et se
[Musique]
parce qu'ils mangent trop de viande bah
pour une partie de l'opinion c'est
radical c'est pour ça que je faisais
pardonnez-moi vous me permettez je pense
que là vous pointez finalement deux
radicalités une radicalité qui va avoir
une visée strictement politicienne et
une autre radicalité celle qui fait
l'objet je crois de cette émission
c'est-à-dire cette activité-là de gens
qui ont envie de faire passer un message
avec des actions multiples et variées
qui que je qualifierais pas d'ailleurs
moi personnellement de radicalité
Isabelle je trouvais que le terme était
pas mal et qui exprime autre chose que
ça ouais mais bon ça se rejoint quand
même à Sainte souligne il y a aussi des
députés
et Yannick Jadot voit sa voiture taguer
etc etc ouais ça se rejoint je vais
essayer de pas tout mélanger
Léa Falco donc sur cette cette idée
d'aller chercher des responsables pour
faire avancer finalement la cause
commune qui est trouvée en des solutions
accélérant sur les solutions qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez alors le la question
est pas d'abord de trouver des
responsables la question est de voir
comment est-ce que ça marche quel lien
causo amène au fait que aujourd'hui le
problème qu'on a c'est qu'on aimait du
CO2 mais trop de CO2 donc problème
causal on regarde comment ça fonctionne
on garde qui émet on regarde comment on
fait pour empêcher des maîtres ou pour
réduire au maximum et compenser par
ailleurs avec typiquement des pics de
carbone en parallèle il faudra aussi
adapter les sociétés ça c'est un autre
problème donc c'est pas la question
c'est compliqué parce que l'adaptation
est importante à faire tout à fait bah
il faut tout faire en même temps et
c'est là la grande difficulté le ces
activistes là j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il cherche un bouc émissaire dans le
dans la petite pastille que vous avez
montré la jeune fille qui parle le dit
de manière d'habillante ce qu'on fait
c'est absurde on aimerait ne pas être là
si on était de l'autre côté de la
barrière derrière nos petits étendards
ça nous emmerderait aussi pardon du
langage donc il ne cherche pas de bouc
émissaire ils essayent de mettre en
lumière une thématique ou en tout cas un
sujet qui est celui bon en l'occurrence
de la rénovation thermique mais ça va
plus loin c'est à dire que il y a aussi
une manière on y reviendra vous nous
l'avez dit donc j'ai hâte d'arriver à
cette partie là mais sur le traitement
médiatique de la question et donc pour
faire disparaître à ses activistes là il
faut arrêter de parler de la forme il
faut parler du fond on est d'accord ils
avaient sommier intervenir sur cette
partie oui je voulais intervenir sur
votre question sur cette question de
génération de de classe et puis de gens
alors si on retire l'aspect on va dire
polémique de la vie politique qui fait
que maintenant est visiblement de plus
en plus il faut faire du buzz et donc
faut pas être dans les nuances on va
dire mais en même temps si on essaye
d'apporter le terme en même temps ça
traduit quand même l'évolution de la
question de la façon dont on cadre les
questions écologiques etc alors d'une
part on a des militants qui sont souvent
des militants jeunes et qui se
présentent sur le registre justement de
la de la génération et pour certains
versus contre les boomers qui en ont
trop profité etc alors ça ça traduit
quand même une tendance assez ancienne
au remplacement des conflits de classe
par de prétendus conflit des générations
sauf que on oublie souvent de dire que
parmi ces militants même s'ils sont
c'est une fraction particulière de la
jeunesse c'est pas toute la jeunesse bon
ensuite évolution pourquoi et porosité
entre quoi et quoi et bien une porosité
qui faudra réinterroger pour comprendre
ce qui se passe actuellement une
porosité croissante entre les milieux de
gauche radicale et milieu écologique ça
c'est absolument net et on le repère au
moins depuis les années 2016-2012 2016
très très clairement dans les deux sens
qui fait que la question écologique
maintenant se pose aussi comme question
anticapitaliste ce qui explique cela et
puis par ailleurs
instrumentalisation de l'écologie par un
parti politique ou non c'est pas des
partis politiques ce sont des groupes
affinitaires donc je par exemple la
présidentielle Jean-Luc Mélenchon se
saisissait de oui mais moi je parle pas
je parle des activistes hors partie si
vous voulez et puis l'autre question qui
est la question du genre on oublie
souvent de rappeler que historiquement
ce des militantes
libertaires ou communiste qui ont posé
Louise Michel la question qui ont liée
la question de l'oppression des femmes
avec la question animale par exemple ou
la journaliste libertaire Séverine qui
fait un petit livre sac à tout mémoire
d'un petit chien ou pour la première
fois on est en 1903 elle fait le lien
entre l'oppression que subissent les
femmes et la question animale et une
question une une animalisation également
d'écologie que l'on voit arriver avec la
question je véganisme de l'antispécisme
etc donc ça traduit aussi eu évolution
alors dans ce dossier on l'a dit il y a
deux types d'événements qui se recoupent
et qu'on va essayer de pas mélanger on
parlera tout à l'heure des des tableaux
des toiles de maître asperger de sauce
tomate de soude etc etc mais il y a
d'abord donc ces manifestations contre
la méga bassine de Sainte-Soline dans
les Deux Sèvres les militants avaient
sectionné des canalisations bloquées des
routes avant d'affronter d'affronter les
les forces de l'ordre il y avait eu 61
blessés dont de graves parmi les forces
de l'ordre et une quarantaine de blessés
parmi les manifestants voilà comment la
première ministre réagissait à
l'Assemblée si la majorité des
manifestants a été pacifiques plusieurs
centaines d'individus violents ont pris
à partir des gendarmes qui protégeaient
le site le bilan de leur action est
lourd tire de mortier j'ai de cocktail
Molotov véhicules de gendarmerie détruit
et une soixantaine de militaires blessés
ce sont des scènes inacceptables et
profondément choquantes malgré la grande
violence de l'agression les gendarmes
ont tenu et sous l'autorité du ministre
de l'intérieur ils ont maintenu l'ordre
républicain et je veux à nouveau les
remercier et leur rendre hommage et
exprimer également toute la solidarité
et la solidarité du gouvernement avec
tous les gendarmes blessés donc je le
dis clairement l'opposition à un projet
ne justifie jamais la violence la
justice est saisie et je peux pour
assurer monsieur le Président il n'y
aura aucune impunité pour ces auteurs de
violence donc ça ce sont les mots de la
première ministre mais Laetitia le
ministre de l'Intérieur évidemment à
parler déco terrorisme le mot à choqué
il l'assume Gérald Darmanin oui je vous
propose qu'on relise ensemble les propos
de Gérald Darmanin dans leur ensemble
c'était justement à l'occasion d'un
point près ça veut dire qu'il a convoqué
les journalistes pour leur dire cela le
30 octobre dernier il y a eu une grande
partie des manifestants violents et qui
s'en sont pris physiquement au gendarmes
les blessants s'en prenant à 5 véhicules
de gendarmerie qui ont été détruits je
veux redire que cela relève de l'écho
terrorisme il y a des gens fichés
radicalisés aux yeux des renseignements
qui veulent le chaos et nous ne pouvons
l'accepter alors ce mot déco terrorisme
Gérald Darmanin l'a répété ensuite donc
il l'assume dans ces interviews dans les
médias mais pas à l'Assemblée nationale
ça veut dire qu'il sait qu'il manie un
terme qui est potentiellement vraiment
inflammable oui et qu'il prend aussi en
compte peut-être même surtout la
réaction de son propre camp parce que si
à gauche évidemment et les écologistes
aussi bien sûr ont tout de suite
condamné très fermement ce terme
d'écotérisme dans son propre camp ça a
quand même posé question et par exemple
la première ministre qu'on vient
d'entendre à l'Assemblée on lui a
demandé de réagir sur ce terme sur BFM
TV lundi soir et regardez ce qu'elle a
répondu ce n'est pas un mot que j'ai
utilisé il a été utilisé par le ministre
de l'Intérieur en référence à des
manifestants extrêmement violents qui
ont pris à partie les forces de l'ordre
plus de 60 gendarmes blessés le
journaliste le journaliste lui dit ce
n'est pas du terrorisme je n'ai pas
employé ce terme mais c'est une violence
intolérable donc on peut parler de
Matignon qui se désolidarise mais il y a
pas eu de réprimante du ministre de
l'Intérieur apparemment non puisque j'ai
eu ce matin au téléphone le conseiller
en communication de Gérald Darmanin qui
m'assure que c'est le Ministre seul qui
a choisi d'utiliser ce mot des
kotorismes qu'il a fait en conscience
pour marquer les esprits et que s'il
fallait il le répéterait donc il a quand
même tenté de minimiser un peu la
polynamique en me disant que c'était un
mot qui était utilisé dans le jargon des
renseignements américains mais aussi des
renseignements français mais quand même
Gérald Darmanin a décidé d'utiliser ce
terme dans sa communication publique car
il veut finalement criminaliser la
protestation écologiste et quand il fait
mention des fichiers s ça sert aussi cet
objectif alors que fichier s ce n'est
pas un statut et puis on va pas se
mentir et travailler aussi un peu quand
même son personnage et son côté toujours
plus Sarkozy évidemment je commence avec
vous les a Falco bon il trace son sillon
politique Gérald darmaninola on l'a bien
compris
c'est quand même dangereux quoi quand il
l'utilise dans la même phrase écologique
terrorisme fichés on voit bien tous les
tous les concepts qu'il est en train de
mélanger quoi absolument vous en
parlerez bien mieux que moi mais oui
vous avez vous réagi comme militante
comme voilà face à ce discours au-delà
au-delà de l'aspect militant c'est quand
même un énorme manque de respect pour
des gens qui sont effectivement victimes
de terrorisme et je trouve ça
hallucinant c'était en plus quelques
jours après quand même le l'anniversaire
des attentats du bateau du Bataclan que
qui prononce ces mots qui les réitère
que donc c'est un élément de langage qui
a été innovembre et là c'était le 30
octobre pardon il les a répété il y a
quelques jours alors courte parce que
voilà on était dans ce contexte
et là du procès du 14 juin
ça veut dire que c'est quand même une
volonté délibérée effectivement dans son
personnage parce que l'explication de ça
fait partie du jargon des des services
de renseignement américain le les
conseils en communication de Gérardin
maintenant savent très bien je pense
qu'il faut séparer les espaces
sémantiques et s'adapter à la population
dans laquelle on parle il y a une
volonté effectivement vous l'avez dit de
criminaliser ses actions là qui en plus
on va on va en parler mais disons que
quand vous envoyez de la soupe sur une
une peinture qui en plus vit on peut pas
vraiment dire qui est d'atteinte ni aux
personnes ni au bien
ça emmène quand même vers des dérives
qui peuvent être inquiétantes sur ce qui
en fait ne relève pas la légalité mais
relève d'action que peuvent décider de
prendre des gens qui en fait se sentent
impuissants dans leur expression
démocratique c'est ça qui se passe c'est
que il y a des gens aujourd'hui en
particulier des jeunes mais pas que qui
se disent que ils n'ont pas voix au
chapitre en tout cas leur revendications
qui je pense la plus importante du 21e
siècle c'est-à-dire le combat pour
l'environnement n'est pas entendu et
donc qui se décide parce qu'ils sont
seuls parce que le combat individuel ne
peut passer malheureusement parfois que
par des choses comme ça à se lancer dans
des actions ce type là si on commence à
utiliser le mode d'éco-terrorisme je
pense qu'on part dans une direction
extrêmement dangereuse oui Antoine quel
peuvent être les conséquences dans
l'opinion de l'utilisation il a tout à
fait raison puisqu'on en parle donc il
fait le buzz après sur le fond moi j'ai
pas envie de continuer voilà ça n'a
absolument aucun sens quand vous avez
des débordements comme ça dans une
manifestation ordinaire vous avez
souvent des Black Blocs on détruit des
il est devanture de magasin etc etc
est-ce que le ministre de l'Intérieur
vient parler de terrorisme
[Musique]
ou la menace d'utiliser la violence de
manière criminelle contre des victimes
innocentes ou des biens par un groupe
d'orientation écologique pour des
raisons politiques liées à
l'environnement ou visant un public au
le haut de la cible et par exemple il y
avait cette incendie dans le Colorado
d'une station de ski ou des activistes
avaient mis le feu à des bâtiments où il
y avait des gens à l'intérieur dans le
Colorado au nom de la protection de
l'habitat naturel du lynx donc il y
avait eu des victimes
et donc aux États-Unis entre 1970 et une
étude qui les a relatés et 2007 17% des
cas ont été jugés équot terroristes ils
sont un autre niveau de radicalité cela
on en est pas du tout là en France pas
du tout pas du tout si on dès qu'il y a
une cause c'est du terrorisme c'est ça
l'idée
cette notion est théorisée par le FBI et
aujourd'hui c'est la première fois en
France effectivement
mais c'est pour ça que c'est c'est
problématiques c'est au-delà de bon
voilà de du mélange des des genres de la
confusion des notions à mon avis dans
l'esprit de de des citoyens français
mais c'est que il s'est passé 20 ans 20
ans de relative ou de Total en fonction
de l'analyse inaction face au
réchauffement climatique donc est-ce
qu'on peut dire ça aujourd'hui de la
même façon qu'on le disait il y a 20 ans
vous voyez ce que je veux dire la
question pardonnez-moi la question
n'est pas là la question est les modes
opératoires et qu'est-ce qu'on fait et
entre ce que font les animalistes et
certains écologistes très radicaux aux
États-Unis ou en Grande-Bretagne où
j'évoquais tout à l'heure que certains
militants lancés du vitriol sur le
visage d'employés d'élevage etc on n'est
pas du tout là on n'est pas du tout là
terrorisme ça renvoie à l'idée de faire
des attentats indiscriminés aveugles
pour susciter pour susciter la peur la
terreur et un effet de sidération alors
en plus dans un contexte quand même très
chargé dans notre pays du fait de des
attentats qui venaient d'être jugés on a
eu un an quand même de procès sur le 13
novembre l'attentat sur terrible sur
à Nice on est l'opinion est dedans quoi
donc c'est quand même c'est quand même
excessif et radical pour le coup de
parler de parler ainsi
ce terme il ne il ne soutient pas mais
le tourisme oui mais d'un point de vue
si vous voulez c'est comme vous disiez
on veut pas dire tout et n'importe quoi
et d'un point de vue scientifique et
d'un point de vue clinique je dirais ça
ne tient pas la route alors mais ça a
des effets
la vraie question c'est de savoir
comment il se fait que compte tenu de
l'urgence écologique il est pas
justement partout dans le monde un
véritable éco terrorisme qui est émergé
moi c'est ça ma grande interrogation ma
grande surprise vous êtes d'accord avec
cette cette idée il a Falco sur le
Conseil d'urgence on peut être d'accord
donc effectivement
une gradation progressive de ce qui va
se passer c'est je vais aller un
corpulence je suis surpris puisque j'ai
travaillé là dessus qu'il n'y ait pas
encore déco islamisme c'est à dire que
le terrorisme islamiste n'est pas
investi la question environnementale ça
me surprend j'espère ne pas donner de
mauvaise idée à ce micro mais je suis
absolument persuadé puisque je fais de
la prospective que ça finira par arriver
écoutez ce sera pas dans une archive de
Lina on montrera la première fois que
cette idée a été diffusée espérons que
ça n'arrivera pas la violence pour
porter une revendication politique
évidemment c'est pas nouveau quand un
calmé vous allez pouvoir nous rejoindre
la France a été secouée par des actions
de ce type à la fin des années 70
pendant les années 80 avec évidemment
action directe donc on parle de violence
qui va jusqu'à l'assassinat absolument
c'est une page noire de l'histoire des
années 80 actions directes est une
organisation armée d'extrême gauche
fondée en 1979 ses premiers militants
viennent de groupes révolutionnaires
internationalistes et anti Franck kyste
et progressivement le groupe désigner
pour cible et bien
l'impératisme capitaliste mais aussi les
symboles de l'ordre établi ou encore le
patronat on va voir quelques photos de
l'époque qu'on a retrouvé dans les
archives une des toutes premières
actions ce sera et bien contre cette
cette
succursale de la préfecture de police de
Paris et en fait on voit que son direct
il revendique la violence comme un mode
opératoire avec l'utilisation d'explosif
le mitraillage des défis publics c'est
ce qui s'est passé ce jour-là la
préfecture de police de Paris et de
magasins de luxe ou encore de banque
action directe à sa création se
revendique comme mouvement je cite pour
l'autonomie du prolétariat c'est
d'ailleurs le patronat qui sera la toute
première cible du groupe musculaire en
1979 on parle entre 1979 et 1987
d'environ 80 attentats ou assassinat les
actions les plus graves sont commises à
partir de 84 lorsque le groupe français
s'est rapproché des Allemands de la
fraction de l'Armée rouge et des
Brigades Rouges italiennes enfin vol
d'arme attentat contre des ministères
contre la police on passe à une autre
phase un peu de 84 avec l'assassinat de
haut gradé comme René Audran ou du
patron de Renault Georges Besse en 1986
on le voit à l'image et donc au final
Jean-Marc rouillant Nathalie Ménigon
jouer LeBron et Georges Cipriani qui
sont les principaux responsables
d'action direct ils sont arrêtés en 1987
et condamné en 89 la région criminelle à
la perpétuité mais ce sont totalement 22
membres de cette mouvance d'extrême
gauche qui seront jugés pour association
de malfaiteurs le dernier des quatre
têtes pensantes d'Action Directe
Jean-Marc Rouen est sorti de prison en
2011 il y aura passé au total 24 années
mais toutes ces années après et bien les
actes commis par action directe elles
font toujours débat dans certains
cercles d'extrême gauche notamment sur
la question de la légitimité de la
violence merci Quentin pour ces
explications Isabelle sommier évidemment
je me tourne vers vous puisque vous avez
étudié ces violences politiques en
France votre ouvrage collectif publié
auprès de Sciences Po est-ce qu'il y a
je sais pas si on peut être aussi
simpliste mais s'il y a des héritiers
d'action direct aujourd'hui
non pour le moment on peut pas dire qui
alors il y a des il y a des des endroits
des espaces de discussions qui s'en
rapprochent le mouvement autonome le
mouvement anarchiste etc mais la
question de la violence se pose pas du
tout aujourd'hui de la façon dont elle
se posait jusqu'aux années 70-80 où il y
avait un vecteur idéologique qui était
le marxisme le marxisme qui justifiait
le recours à la violence
ce n'est plus véritablement le cas à
part le jihad oui c'est une légitimation
de type idéologique ce qui se développe
c'est des légitimations de ce type
instrumental on a tout essayé sauf la
violence donc et c'est ça le risque
c'est effectivement la montée en
radicalité jusqu'au recours à la
violence par le sentiment de désespoir
et d'être pas entendu d'être inaudible
mais ces deux phénomènes absolument
différents sur la base auquel vous
faites référence les faits des
écologistes radicaux et des animalistes
c'est un vingtième à la base et c'est
dans 8 cas sur 10 ce sont des
dégradations et des destructions et il y
a 10% ce sont des affrontements parce
que c'est dans le cadre des des ADDES ou
voilà donc on est plus du tout c'est
très quand on regarde les les
revendications de la violence il y en a
à peu près 40 % qui sont revendiqués
c'est très difficile de trouver des
revendications de violences contre des
personnes contre les biens oui ce qui
montre quand même la force du processus
de civilisation même si et là des
événements de France ou absolument vous
voyez sur une base de données inédite
que nous avons réalisé sur six mille
épisodes de violence et donc au total
9000 fées de violence parce que dans un
épisode il peut y avoir de
l'affrontement et des dégradations un
mot rapide là-dessus ensuite on parle du
traitement médiatique parce que on est
parti d'une étudiante qui bloquait le
périph en se collant et on arrive à
action directe bon ben on essaye de
prendre un peu de recul non mais on
essaie de prendre un peu de recul et et
grâce à isamel sommier de mener de la le
recul historique il est intéressant dans
un des vacances on parle de radicalité
politique de réalité écologique ben
pardon mais le dernier exemple et le
pire c'est cette action directe je dis
pas qui on va aller jusque là forcément
mais est-ce qu'on peut vous êtes
vous-même poser la question de
l'hypothèse que face à l'inaction des
gouvernements et une partie de la
population qui se règle encore
oui mais vous venez de dire que c'était
possible bah oui je peux dire pas
d'amalgame si vous mal permettez si vous
voulez moi je pense pour ajouter
à ce que vous faites mais en disant ça
n'a rien à voir pour l'instant ça n'a
rien et vous avez vous-même dit il y a
pardon 5 minutes que c'était un risque
non j'ai dit c'est étonnant que ça ne
soit pas arrivé
on est toujours au cœur de cette de ce
débat finalement du traitement
médiatique de cette activité écologique
je vous propose de revoir les une de nos
confrères des new magazine comme on dit
de L'Express à Paris Match en passant
par le point Marianne et Valeurs
Actuelles tous les hebdos du week-end
dernier titre sur alors les titres sont
différents les bouchons du climat la
génération des écolos radicaux il
mélange d'ailleurs en quand on va aller
une ceux qui aspergent les tableaux et
ceux qui affrontent les gendarmes à
Sainte-Souline moi j'ai trouvé ça assez
caricatural Léa Falco qu'est-ce que ça
révèle pour vous ce traitement
médiatique ça va au-delà de ces journaux
là parce que il y a une partie des
journaux que vous avez montré qui sont
qui ont une ligne idéologique résolument
anti-écologiste c'est pas la première
fois c'est pas la dernière fois que
valeur actuelle tape sur les écolos donc
c'est y compris dans les médias très
généralistes y compris dans des médias
qui sont qui sont plutôt bons en général
sur les questions climatiques il y a ce
focus là qui est fait sur le la forme
plutôt que le fond et en fait c'est un
ça revient un peu à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est que si on veut
faire disparaître ce type de
mobilisation et bien il faut qu'on parle
du fond les médias c'est la deuxième
source d'information des gens le premier
c'est les profs les proches le deuxième
c'est les médias donc il y a a besoin de
parler simplement du fond du problème
qui est extrêmement complexe et la
difficulté d'action de ce type là
d'action de dernière rénovation ou
d'action des lanceurs des lanceurs de
soupes c'est qu'il y a pas de lien
direct entre ce qu'ils font et leur
revendications quand vous avez quelqu'un
qui se colle la main à une voiture on
comprend de quoi on peut parler on peut
parler de tout le système qui est
derrière
il y a une cohérence il y a une
cohérence la voiture le symbole de la
voiture la revendication de dernière
rénovation c'est la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments et ils bloque le
périphérique c'est pas directement en
lien on peut on peut ensuite élaborer je
pense que c'est le rôle des médias de le
faire mais là je pense vous incluez les
réseaux sociaux les réseaux sociaux ils
sont ils sont pas dirigés par par une
ligne éditoriale les médias le sont
c'est une différence qui est
fondamentale
j'interviens un peu trop dans ce débat
mais ce qui était frappant c'était
c'était le fait d'avoir tous les news
magazines le même week-end ils sortent
tous le mercredi ou jeudi et ils étaient
tous sur la même sur finalement la même
critique
plus ou moins sous-jacente plus ou moins
assumer de de la radicalité écologiste
oui bah écoutez c'est aussi un choix
politique de leur part encore une fois
c'est pas non plus n'importe quel média
qui ont fait leur une là-dessus ils en
ont tous parlé pas tous de la même
manière il y a des médias qui ont aussi
donné une partie d'informations une
partie de d'antenne au fond la dernière
fois je suis passé sur le une autre
chaîne on m'a interrogé justement sur le
jet de le jet soupe c'était sur le jet
soupe le segment juste avant moi c'était
sur les températures exceptionnelles qui
faisaient et le fait que les gens
puissent partir en vacances alors qu'on
était mi-octobre fin octobre et que
c'était plutôt positif vous voyez il y a
une disjonction complète une dissonance
cognitive dans la manière dont on traite
l'information du côté des rédactions qui
va falloir combler à un moment ou un
autre pas à faire du côté des médias qui
c'est sûr vont très souvent vers la
facilité il y a aussi peut-être une
réflexion à avoir du côté de ceux qui
veulent communiquer la communication il
y a un émetteur il y a un récepteur
d'accord entre les deux et puis ensuite
avec vous mais si vous voulez faire
c'est des messages et si vous souhaitez
que les médias s'intéressent au fond
peut-être qu'il faut changer la forme
dont vous envoyez les messages et
peut-être aussi le fond de vos messages
mais je suis tout à fait responsable de
votre message le problème c'est que moi
je fais pas de résistance civile ou de
désobéissance civile selon ce que vous
appelez moi je suis membre d'un
collectif qui s'appelle power écologique
ce qu'on fait c'est des rapports donc on
fait des rapports sur l'emploi des
rapports sectoriels sur l'évolution vous
allez avoir dans les grandes boîtes on
en parle jamais on en parle jamais parce
que ça n'intéresse pas les médias que
mais c'est pas une critique c'est
simplement le fonctionnement
ont bénéficié d'un traitement médiatique
je suis d'accord avec vous sur le sur la
forme que ça prend mais le problème
c'est exactement ça c'est le traitement
instrumental c'est que on a tenté par on
je dis les militants écologistes en
général il y en a de plein de types mais
on a tenté de parler du fond et ça ne
fonctionne pas parce que le l'émetteur
c'est à dire les rédactions les
journalistes et je vis pas spécialement
cette émission évidemment mais les
journalistes en général c'est que il y a
une il y a une lentille qui fait qu'on
n'arrive pas tout à fait rapport de GIEC
on en parle enfin franchement alors là
chaque rapport du GIEC vous avez pas à
la une de tous les magasins
c'est peut-être un c'est peut-être un
effet de de simple exposition c'est à
dire que quand on pense quand on connaît
un sujet on a l'impression de l'entendre
souvent et moi j'ai tout le temps
l'impression avec le film mais parce que
je suis dans des bulles médiatiques
également et en fait le rapport du GIEC
il y a eu il y a eu un certain nombre
d'études qui ont été faites statistiques
pour voir quel temps d'antenne avait le
rapport du GIEC et par exemple le
deuxième volet du rapport du GECK a eu
je crois 2,7% de temps d'antenne pendant
le mois de sa sortie et il y a un grand
nombre de chaînes qui n'en ont pas du
tout parlé donc je comprends ce
positionnement là mais à la fois on
constate que au vu de la transversalité
complète du sujet comme il a brave
absolument tous les autres thèmes il
faut qu'on cesse de le réduire à
simplement aujourd'hui on parle
d'écologie et qu'on puisse parler
d'écologie dans tous les thèmes c'est la
difficulté aussi Antoine bueno c'est que
le rapport du GIEC c'est un outil
complexe à manier pour les journalistes
c'est c'est une somme et c'est plus
facile évidemment on va revoir les
images de
des deux manifestantes qui leur groupe
d'activistes c'est just stop oil qui
jette de la soupe sur le les tournesols
de de Van Gogh et se collent les mains
au mur on est à la nationale galerie à
Londres et puis ensuite il y a eu des
actions similaires un peu partout
Antoine bueno bah oui ça moi un
journaliste c'est plus facile à montrer
et analyser que rapport du GIEC à
digérer quoi c'est je fais mon je me
mets dans l'autocritique c'est une
extrême c'est une extrême efficacité bah
oui je dis chapeau ça marche ça marche
du tonnerre et après il faut bien voir
qu'il y a le court terme mais le long
terme à court terme on peut les traiter
de bouffon à long terme la véritable
cible ce sont les décideurs politiques
tout ça quelle que soit l'action sacré
sans mauvais jeu de mots un climat
d'urgence environnementale et donc ça
finit par se traduire en action donc je
suis pas sûr que ce soit c'est inutile
que ça preuve en est il y a même un
mouvement de scientifique je crois que
c'est scientist rebellion c'est des gens
qui sont extrêmement sérieux et qui sont
sortis de leur labo qui sont sortis de
leur bureau pour aller mener ses actions
en disant ben c'est peut-être comme ça
que je vais être entendu
que je travaille sur mon livre là et on
me demande de parler de ça je me demande
si je veux pas passer à autre chose
à une série de vidéos vous avez eu sur
les réseaux sociaux pour répondre à
toutes ces questions donc c'est quand
même une question dans lequel il y a un
certain nombre de vérités un peu
dissimulées mais en terme d'exercice de
communication c'est bien fait ils
avaient le sommier si on reprend on
terminera ce débat là-dessus le voilà
ces actions dans les musées c'est vrai
que la première réaction c'est de se
dire mais pourquoi elle est là quoi elle
est là ça a été bien dit parce que c'est
on est dans l'ère du des médias et il
faut faire une image ça j'ai moi claire
quand même ah bah oui ça c'est clair
alors la question effectivement c'est
est-ce que on parle d'abord de l'acte où
on parle de la cause et là on parle plus
de l'acte que de la cause à l'inverse
par exemple vous avez évoqué à juste
titre les faucheurs volontaires
principes de la désobéissance civile où
on voit le lien ou le lien qui pourrait
être fait entre une voiture etc mais là
effectivement on ne le voit pas et c'est
ça la question de l'efficacité est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui est mis en valeur
c'est l'acte ou c'est la cause et là sur
l'affaire enfin sur les affaires dans
les musées c'est l'acte en lui-même
c'est peu la cause alors et la
difficulté pour revenir sur le petit
début de polémique et qui a agité ce
Platon
c'est que beaucoup agacé le présentateur
faut pas qu'il ronronne le présentateur
médiatique qui doit être maintenue le
risque c'est qu'effectivement les médias
c'est une belle image ça fait 10 belles
images mais bon ils sont vides saturés
ils sont vite les donc le risque c'est
d'une montée en radicalité pour
continuer à capter l'attention
médiatique merci la responsabilité
je veux juste vous montrer on parlait du
GIEC et c'est complexe quelque chose qui
je pense motive ceux qui font des
blocages ça c'est un graphique qui sort
du dernier rapport du GIEC qui montre
les scénarios possibles d'émission de
gaz à effet de serre c'est ça le
problème auquel on est confronté il faut
qu'on les réduise et c'est scénarios là
je vous prends encore une seconde et
demi hymen a des futurs qui sont
radicalement différents c'est à dire que
là c'est la température qu'on a eu
depuis le début de la révolution
industrielle là on est au niveau de ces
petits points blancs et on a le choix
grâce à nos choix politiques aujourd'hui
notre débat il essaie sur les modes
d'action on a fait vous pouvez en
témoigner parce que vous avez participé
plusieurs fois de nombreux débats sur
elle vient de faire un c'est très bien
mais on a fait de nombreux débats sur
l'écologie sur les moyens de remédier au
réchauffement climatique vous pouvez en
témoigner ce n'est pas une mine de cette
émission il est sur la Chalette le
présentateur et il est en retard donc il
dit au revoir il remercie tout le monde
ici quand même les livres violences
politiques en France paru au presse de
Sciences Po et puis d'effondrement du
monde n'aura probablement pas lieu
publié chez Flammarion à demain demain
tiens sur notre antenne on va continuer
de parler de transformation écologique
ou de transition écologique puisque
c'est l'intitulé de son ministère
Christophe bechuit il sera invité Dorian
pour le retard
[Musique]